social media influencer and tick tocker
savannah edward savannah thanks so much
for joining me tonight
hi thank you for having me it's a
pleasure to have you on i know that
this type of thing infuriates you
because of the message that it sends
to the youngest and most impressionable
americans what are your thoughts on
how aggressive our public schools are
becoming in pushing this narrative on
the youngest school children
it reminds me when i was an elementary
school student
and so much effort was put into
building relationships with the police
and that we're
pulling away from that seems
counterintuitive because if relations
with the police are so bad then why
aren't we making
effort to rebuild those relationships
and so that our children will have
better relationships with the police
we want to have those relationships be
positive in part because we want
children who are being abused or who are
in bad situations at home
to feel the ability to come forward and
to share that truth about what's going
on there
not to be afraid or intimidated out of
it but there's a whole host of reasons
that we ought to
hold the police in respect and in
positions of respect
and teach that at the youngest ages why
do you believe that this
whole uh anti-cop message and and really
a sort of anti-respect for traditional
american uh
values when it comes to these
institutions of life has taken over our
public schools
that's the million-dollar question it
doesn't make any sense i understand why
the narrative is this way
it's like i said it's counterintuitive
it's not productive
we're damaging our children by teaching
them not to respect authority so what
happens when they do go on the road and
they get their license
and they do encounter a police officer
we're not teaching them now how to
have that relationship we're just going
to see what we
all saw last year yeah you know savannah
i know that you're very familiar
with the kind of performative uh steps
taken by so many
white leftist women particularly wealthy
ones
who go out on social media and pretend
to espouse
these different views or maybe you know
really believe them and i know that
you're someone who's become known for
pushing back against them
what can be done for those of us who
want to see their narrative pushed back
against
to make our voices heard and to support
you and others
who say the truth in response to their
lies
don't be scared i think it's fear
because you know it's the internet age
and
people can get canceled people get
doxxed
people get their lives threatened don't
be scared you
just speak god gave you a voice use it
it's incredible how much can be done by
people who have the bravery to do that
i know that you're one of them and i
thank you for joining me tonight
savannah
thank you for having me hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else